these are the latest labor market  statistics from the office for national  statistics and as you mentioned there  unemployment has fallen again it's down  to 3.6  according to the ons that is the lowest  figure for unemployment since  1974. but that number which appears  optimistic for the economy conceals the  truth of the impact of inflation on  wages which despite pay increases  averaging more than five percent across  the public and private sector real terms  wages measured against cpi inflation are  down  3.9 percent so because of the soaring  cost of living driven primarily by  energy prices we've been discussing for  many months the real cost the real the  real value of wages in people's pay  packets on a weekly and monthly basis is  falling 3.9  so while uh political hostilities and  activity appears to have paused during  this period of national mourning the  impact of the cost of living squeeze is  still being felt very acutely by people  across the country